[Musique]
j'ai travaillé sur des émissions comme
Télématin après je suis parti avec Cyril
Lignac sur M6 et aujourd'hui j'ai une
émission de radio tous les samedis sur
RTL sur la gastronomie évidemment je
suis journaliste gastronomique
[Musique]
c'est important parce que ils sont
jeunes que je m'estime aussi un peu
jeune et que je vois tellement faire de
choses dans la vie on peut tellement
changer le cours des choses
j'ai des objectifs j'ai plein de rêves
j'y arrive j'ai envie d'avancer j'ai
envie de les emmener en fait avec moi
parce que on a cette jeunesse on a cette
fraîcheur on allait on est en bonne
santé on est dynamique et j'ai envie de
leur prouver qu'ils peuvent se faire
confiance qu'ils peuvent être fiers
d'eux déjà en venant ici en s'inscrivant
au parcours du goût en participant au
parcours du goût et j'ai vraiment voilà
envie de soit de l'ordre de confiance de
leur redonner confiance s'ils l'ont
perdu leur dire que je suis là que je
peux les écouter et puis échanger
peut-être les valeurs que j'ai les
valeurs de respect du travail
la solidarité des choses comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça réunit la cuisine c'est la générosité
c'est le partage donc déjà ça fait du
bien pour commencer donc ayant une
passion pour la cuisine
je peux essayer de la transmettre ça
peut fédérer et en quoi ça peut être un
vecteur ben ce sont des métiers qui sont
accessibles moi j'ai pas fait 15 ans
d'études de maths ou de je ne sais quoi
pour pour faire ce métier et donc voilà
la cuisine c'est accessible en revanche
je peux travailler mais ça a apporté de
main et c'est un métier qui est
absolument merveilleux
[Musique]